MEAN, BUSINESS GOOD EVENING.
>> TONIGHT, THE PRESIDENT OF
THE EUROPEAN CENTRAL BANK TELLS
ME SHE HAS NO REGRETS ABOUT HOW
WARNINGS ON DONALD TRUMP I
SPOKE TO PRESIDENT OF GOD AND
AN EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW AS THE
ECB REACHES A TURNING POINT ON
MONETARY POLICY SHE TELLS ME,
WHILE INFLATION IS COMFORTABLY
ON THE WAY DOWN, IT'S STILL TOO
SOON FOR RATE CUTS. AND EUROPE
NEEDS TO GET ITS ACT TOGETHER
TO PREPARE FOR THE POSSIBILITY
OF ANOTHER TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
SHE SAID SHE INTENDS TO REMAIN
IN HER POSITION UNTIL SHE
FULFILLS THE BANKS MANDATE. AND
THAT'S GETTING INFLATION BACK
TO 2% IT WAS A GOOD MEETING. WE
HAD AT THE ECB HEADQUARTERS AND
I PUSHED MADAM REGARD ON WHEN
RATE CUTS FROM THE CENTRAL BANK
WILL BE APPROPRIATE WE ARE NOT
THERE YET, AND WE NEED MORE
DATA, MORE INTELLIGENCE, MORE
>> CERTAINTY THAT WE ARE GOING
TO HIT THAT MEDIUM-TERM TARGET.
AND FOR THAT WE NEED ALL SORTS
OF DATA. BUT ONE OF WHICH IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT, IT'S THE
DATA CONCERNING WAGES INFLATION
NUMBERS FOR UNDERSTANDABLE
REASONS HAVE RISEN IN SOME
COUNTRY, IN SOME IMPORTANT
COUNTRIES, WE EXPECTED THAT WE
KNEW IT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN, SO
WE WENT FROM 2.4 IN NOVEMBER TO
2.9 IN DECEMBER. WE ACTUALLY
HAD ANTICIPATED A LITTLE MORE
THAN THAT BUT BE THAT AS IT
MAY, WE ARE ON THE
DISINFLATIONARY TREND. NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT. BUT WE NEED
TO BE FURTHER INTO THAT
PROCESS.
>> WHAT DOES THAT PROCESS?
>> WELL, WE NEED TO HAVE THREE
KEY COMPONENTS. WE NEED THE
INFLATION OUTLOOK. WHERE ARE WE
AT THE END OF 24? WHERE ARE WE
AT THE END OF 25? WHERE ARE WE
AT THE END OF 26? THAT'S
ROUGHLY THE 3-YEARS PROJECTIONS
THAT WE HAVE. THAT'S 0.1 1.2.
WE NEED UNDERLYING INFLATION TO
ALSO BE HEADING IN THAT
DIRECTION BECAUSE WE CANNOT BE
ONLY DISTRACTED BY ELEMENTS
THAT ARE VERY VOLATILE. YOU
LOOK AT THE PRICE OF OIL, GAS,
ELECTRICITY, FOOD TO A CERTAIN
POINT.
>> THAT'S VERY VOLATILE. WE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND WHETHER THE
CORE INFLATION IS. ALSO ON THAT
DECLINING PATH. AND THIRD, WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT MONETARY
POLICY STANCE ON INTEREST
RATES, IF YOU WILL, IS
TRANSMITTED IN THE FINANCING
TERMS AND CONDITIONS OFFERED TO
ALL CORPORATES, HOUSEHOLD,
SOVEREIGN, AND THEN INTO THE
ECONOMY THIS 2% NUMBER YOU'RE
COMMITTED TO REACHING IT. BUT
AT THE SAME TIME, EVERYBODY
SAYS NO YOU WILL ALL BUDGE
BEFORE YOU GET THERE BECAUSE IF
YOU HAVE TO PUSH HARD ENOUGH TO
GET TO 2%, YOU WILL TIP THE
ECONOMY ZONE OVER THE LAST MILE
WILL BE FUDGED
>> WE HAVE ONE MISSION
DIFFERENT FROM THE FED, WHICH
HAS A DOUBLE MANDATE WHERE ONE
MANDATE, AND THAT IS PRICE
STABILITY, DEFINED AS 2%
MEDIUM-TERM. AND WE WILL GET
THERE WHEN IN A TIMELY MANNER
>> THE RELUCTANCE TO GIVE ME OR
ANYBODY, SOME IDEA THAT YOU ARE
MORE THINKING OF CUTTING BEFORE
THE END OF THE OTHER, NOTES OR
SOME FORM OF INDICATION WHERE
YOU ARE IN THE PROCESS. TREND,
I THINK TENDS PEOPLE RICHARD
KNOW, I THINK
>> EVERYONE FROM THE, THE
BIGGEST HAWKS TO THE SMALL
HELLO, DOVES. I THINK WE ALL
AGREE THAT THE MOOD, THE NEXT
MOVE WILL BE NEXT MOVE, MEANING
IF WE DON'T HOLD, OKAY? IF WE
HAVE THE OPTION OF EITHER
CUTTING OR HIKING WILL BE A
CUT. I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT
THIS IS THE NEXT MOVE. THERE
MIGHT BE A HOLD AND HOLD AND
HOLD ON, HOLD BUT THE NEXT MOVE
WILL BE DOWNWARD. I THINK
EVERYBODY EVERYBODY EXCEPT THAT
IT'S WHEN YOU'RE NOT GIVING ME
ANYTHING THAT SUGGESTS IT MIGHT
BE SOONER RATHER THAN LATER.
>> NO. AND I SHOULDN'T I CANNOT
AT THE SAME TIME SAY WE ARE
DATA DEPENDENT AND TELL YOU
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER. COME
ON, DO THAT
>> I'VE READ YOUR WORDS ON
WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT THE
ELECTION OF DONALD TRUMP AND
VERY CAREFULLY AND ONE LEVEL,
IT'S UNIMPEACHABLE. PARDON THE
PHRASE IN THE SENSE THAT YOU
WERE MERELY STATING THE OBVIOUS
IF HE'S IF HE'S ELECTED, HE
HAS A RANGE OF POLICIES THAT
WILL BE VERY DIFFICULT FOR THE
EUROPEAN VALUES. BUT THE FACT
THAT YOU SET IT THE MERE FACT
THAT YOU SAID IT WHERE MOST
PEOPLE ARE RUNNING FOR THE
HILLS TO SAY NOTHING
CONTROVERSIAL. DO YOU REGRET
SAYING THAT?
>> NO, I DON'T.
>> IS IT THAT MUCH OF A THREAT
TO EUROPEAN BUT I DON'T,
BECAUSE FIRST OF ALL, I THINK
THAT'S BEING CONSTANTLY
POLITICALLY CORRECTLY.
>> AND
>> PERFECT IN THAT RESPECT IS A
RISK OF NOT SEEING THE REALITY
AND PREPARING FOR IT. AND I
THINK THAT IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT
THOSE ZEROS WHERE WHEN TRUMP
WHEN MR. TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES LOOKING AT
HIS PROGRAM NOW, SHOULDN'T
PREVENT YOU FROM UNDERSTANDING
THAT THERE COULD BE THREATS AND
THERE COULD BE ISSUES FOR WHICH
THE EUROPEANS SHOULD BE
PREPARED.
>> WHAT SORT OF PREPARATION ARE
YOU IMAGINING?
>> LET ME GIVE YOU TWO EXAMPLES
HERE. THE FIRST ONE IS WHAT I
CALL THE CAPITAL MARKET UNION,
TRANSFORMING ACCESS TO FINANCE
FOR SMES, SMALL, MEDIUM SIZED
ENTERPRISES, FOR LARGE
CORPORATES MOVING AWAY FROM
LENDING AND MORE TO EQUITY IN
ORDER TO FACILITATE AND
ENCOURAGE INNOVATION. SECOND
EXAMPLE, WE HAVE SOMETHING THAT
IS CALLED HERE, THE SINGLE
MARKET. WELL, IT'S ONLY A
SINGLE TO A POINT BECAUSE WHEN
YOU LOOK AT SOME SERVICES, FOR
INSTANCE, IT IS NOT YET SINGLE.
YOU NEED TO HAVE AN EQUIVALENT,
YOU NEED TO HAVE A LICENSE, YOU
NEED TO DO THIS AND THAT WHICH
IS DIFFERENT, WHETHER YOU WANT
TO APPLY THAT, THAT THAT
PROFESSIONAL SKILLS OF YEARS IN
GERMANY OR IN FINLAND, OR IN
FRANCE. SO THE BENEFIT OF BEING
MORE AND REALLY A SINGLE MARKET
IS TREMENDOUS. AND I THINK WE
HAVE TO JUST MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION. THAT'S HOW EUROPE
MOVES BY THE WAY. WHEN IT IS
UNDER THREAT. SO GOOD, LET'S
MOVE.
>> WHAT HAPPENED FOUR YEARS AGO
TO JOIN THE LAST TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WITH THE
QUESTION OF TARIFFS WITH THE
SABER-RATTLING I MEAN, YOU ARE
REALLY SAYING IF I UNDERSTAND
YOU DON'T BE SURPRISED IF IT
HAPPENS AGAIN CERTAINLY NOT NOW
WE'VE BEEN WARNED.
>> THAT'S CORRECT. AND
THEREFORE, LET US PREPARE FOR
THAT. LET US PREPARE FOR
POTENTIAL TARIFFS FROM
POTENTIAL HARSH DECISIONS THAT
WOUND WOULD BE UNEXPECTED SO
LET US BE STRONG AT HOME
>> I DON'T EXPECT YOU TO GIVE
ME NAMES BUT HAVE YOU HAD
PEOPLE RING YOU UP AND SAY,